all of that still counts as a
relationship thank you Frank
till I get a wedding ring oh I'm stocked
and what I've heard today hi my name is
Joyce and I've been settling petty
disputes since the day I was born
because I'm a bad and I'm joined by my
right hitter Gallo my Bayless you know
what it is
plaintiff kaeleen is bringing defendant
Michael to petty Court today as there
has been endless debate over the age-old
question can exes be friends welcome to
petit Court my going to you looking
forward to today's ruling hoping to
finally put this issue in the past and
ready to move on okay Mike report
because I do think in fact that exes can
be friends seeing that we have been
friends and in a relationship for about
seven years
we started out sophomore year of college
as friends and then eventually he left
the friend zone and now I feel that it
would make sense that we would still be
friends
seeing that we started as friends okay
okay the defendant speaks his case
Michael as it pertains to this case Your
Honor in my opinion I do not believe
exes can be friends for the following
reasons the plaintiff has demonstrated
jealous behavior in the past which is
detrimental to the well-being of the
defendant myself and anybody involved
with the defendant so you can see how
that can be problematic Your Honor may I
interject just just a little bit here
absolutely kaeleen well I would like to
point out that the moment that this
person here is furn to is actually
during college you know college life
you're a little here and there
everywhere you don't really know who you
are just yet
we are now three years out of college I
think we have both shown signs of
maturity and I think that a friendship
can in fact evolve Your Honor it's it's
interesting that we're having the
discussion about exes seeing that
Caitlyn and I are not exes in the
traditional sense
the court has maybe as the Drake line
goes pinky ring till I get a wedding
ring okay and keen and I I said we were
in a seven-year situation - if any and
with that being said I don't even know
I'm in court today we may speak number
one I feel like that is the issue with
this generation and this is a prime
example investing time investing love
investing yourself into another person
regardless of if it was boyfriend and
girlfriend still counts as a
relationship regardless number one I
think calm down
thank you and number two if I do go back
to my history here I do want to make it
clear that we did in fact date for at
least a week now I get it I get it that
is not that's nothing technically
compared to the seven-year time span
right but at the end of the day was this
man not someone that I told all of my
deepest darkest secrets - what does not
know one man that I went to to laugh
with yes so one man that you played
okay um Michael please come to the court
and speak your truth I wish I had some
wine let's get started in the past and
you may be asking you know why why
didn't it work out between the two of us
I'm here today to tell you that it
didn't work out because the plaintiff
was unserious about the defendant often
times she let the defendant or other
people while I was here taking care of
the home you can understand how a
resentment can develop and build and in
large part due to her failures to be a
good partner before you answer I will
say something this relationship it
sounds like friends with benefits
I dunno pay lien on a personal level so
I know that she was probably protecting
herself in her heart but in a
relationship it takes two to make a
failure so let's make sure in this court
we are honest because petty always has a
little bit of truth I just want to say
that when I was very serious about
making a commitment to this man he
himself I get it like he wanted to
protect himself at that point he was not
serious so I do feel as though we have
never been on the same page which could
also result into why we are now exes and
I also want to say that excess can be
friends because number one I can give
you examples we have Jason Momoa right
and Lisa Bonet they are together right
but of course she was with Lenny Kravitz
and Lenny Kravitz and Lisa Bonet have a
great relationship and the two guys
actually I'm sorry they have matching
rings because they're just so close so
they are able to co-exist together
another example Will Smith and Jada and
Sheree okay they are doing their thing
and they are raising multiple children
together and they are all friends okay
there are many cases of relationships
that didn't go well or haven't gone well
a large case in point era and future
their relationship is problematic that's
that's debatable and hearsay your honor
all right all right let's bring the
witness to the stand okay
actually Your Honor I object the defense
has not had any prior knowledge of this
witness entering the courtroom well
ready so the witness come up witness
please introduce yourself hello my name
is Jimmy
I'm Kelly's coworker you say the whole
truth real truth and nothing but the
truth so help you God
yeah or that word first of all Your
Honor I'm shocked and what I've heard
today
they were spilling tea that I didn't
expect to be so much this is then it's
not gonna be in this courtroom that is
very true Barney you're right your honor
yeah Anna I do believe in some instances
that exes can be friends I think it
takes an enormous amount of maturity and
it also depends on how people broke up
and if they have healed from their prior
breakup how is your prior experiences we
know that you recently um and in a
relationship in the course of the year
first of all I don't like petty court
because we're bringing up Bo who's that
I didn't get an ex to bring up Peter the
judge I am in a healthy friendship phase
with my eggs
I am I apologize for wrongdoings she has
apologized for her own doings as well we
have kept distance from each other but
also remain in communication that is
healthy and forward moving and not on
backside your honor and my backside let
the record show I mean clap those cheeks
somebody asking or it sonographer to
write that down you know if you're gonna
be friends you got to be friends and
that means you can't do anything not
even the tip Jana not even a fan is my
ex attractive enough where you know I
would want to cut short
okay buddy I know I can't because there
are barriers and parameters in which I
had to protect alright your honor we had
enough of his men we're gonna bring the
paint up and defend it
so I say what else about you know my
family would up y'all all right you can
leave okay okay bye okay I do want
something to discuss a question I have
for the defendant and plaintiff what is
your sexual chemistry
um Your Honor I'd like to exercise my
Fifth Amendment right to plead the fifth
what is your sign your chart please
comments well I am a cancer mm Your
Honor I am a Capricorn
do you see God yeah I'm definitely
someone Capricorn I could tell Michael
that you are someone who comes from very
balanced worlds what your issue is that
you are not as forgiving as you should
be because you hold people to the
standards that you have for yourself
which is already too high which puts you
in a place of constantly trying to reach
a goal without ever realizing all the
success you've already have an email
said on the fun parts and things cancer
I mean let's talk about it I'm born and
bred for my cancer I swear on my cancers
most of my holes or cancers I can't
escape the problem is is that you guys
don't know how to let go it's the it's
the issue of loving and caring and
appreciating someone so much but once
that person cracks the show they sit in
the little spot in under your shell and
you cannot let them go and the only
person that you really need to be there
for it was yourself put yourself on a
higher pedestal
taylean I have one more question for you
yes your honor
after what you've heard today do you
even want to still be friends with your
ex to be honest because I know his heart
I want to say yes but because he thinks
with his mind he definitely wouldn't be
open to it
so I guess the answer is no okay I think
I've heard enough and I have my final
verdict all rise
I have come down with my final verdict
my final verdict is neither because I do
believe that exes can be friends with
time
maturity and being honest with
yourselves and I think the both of you
aren't being honest with yourself
Michael
is putting up walls because he has been
hurt by you and he's like most men when
they've been hurt they put up all so
thick that they can't even see and
Kayleen you are fighting for a version
of your friendship that does not exist
anymore you need to find a new
friendship you guys are not going to
have the same relationship there will
not be moments of the same intimacy and
the both of you still have feelings for
each other in some way so before you can
even be friends you guys need to spend
time apart to heal the relationship and
end it for good you have to really start
a new slate and look at that person like
you're meeting them for the first time
all right I just want to thank you guys
for gathering in our court today and
I'll get some trap cheese some oxtail
thank you your honor Thank You bailiff
for your time
Court is adjourned can I leave oh I just
came back from court and I do feel like
Judge Joyce's ruling was interesting to
say the least it wasn't the ruling that
I wanted to hear but perhaps it was a
ruling that I needed to hear you know we
make mistakes we all make mistakes and
we can't take them back but we can learn
from them and hopefully one day one
we're both emotionally mature enough we
can eventually develop a friendship that
is healthy and respectful for both
parties
because again time heals all
that's all I gotta say about that thanks
Joyce Joyce
[Music]
you
[Music]